those words are ashes in my mouth now
what i was doing was stating what
china had said it would do
and it had signed up to that in an
international treaty called the joint
declaration
lodged at the u.n
and to be absolutely blunt
it's completely reneged on that 100
percent
and as several newspapers have been
saying and magazines
here and abroad
it's um in the process of turning
a once free and open society arguably
the freest and most open in asia into a
police state do you think it was
inevitable that that was going to happen
did you know at the time
in the back of your mind that it was
inevitable no i didn't know and or think
it was inevitable um and it's true to
say that for
maybe a dozen years after we left in
1997
um under zhang jimin and hujin tao the
first two presidents after 97.
things went on reasonably well
there was too much interference there
was an attempt then to introduce a
national security law which failed
because of the huge demonstrations in
hong kong
and the chinese went back on their
commitments to develop democracy but by
and large until
2012 2013 hong kong was the same place
that it had been
that we all remember but what changed
was xi jinping
who cracked down everywhere
i think the leadership was worried that
things were slipping out of their
control
and they just as they cracked down on
civil society in china
and any descent in china
and in xinjiang and in tibet
so they cracked down in hong kong and
the problem for hong kong
was it represented all the things which
the chinese communist party
today
think represent an existential threat to
their continuing
held of power
there was i was there at the time and it
seemed to me there was this idea that
perhaps as china opened up economically
it would also
you know become slightly more liberal
politically
that
was flawed optimism do you think yes it
was and it was often
based on
a misreading of what was happening in
china
after the chinese had
had joined the world trade organization
and i was one of the european
commissioners who helped to negotiate
the european side of that
tony blair with his
wonderful
hey chaps optimism
said that the chinese road to democracy
was now unstoppable
well
something stopped
um and i think that it's true been true
all along
that a lot of our assessments of china
have represented wishful thinking
do you think china under xi jinping as a
threat to the world
order
in a similar way to russia
in the sense of
possibly
invading taiwan
do you think it's a similar threat it
could be
what i think it is
is a threat to into an international
rules-based order whether it's economic
or social or whatever
because there is one thing which is
absolutely clear
my main critic when i was in hong kong
who was very critical of my attempts to
do a limited amount to entrench
democracy and protection of the
of human rights and so on my main critic
used to say about the chinese leadership
they may be thuggish dictators he used
to say but they're men of their word
now we know that part of that is true
the first bit but the second bit is not
true
and they break treaties they break
agreements right left and center
and one of them is the agreement on hong
kong
i don't believe that um
they probably represent the same threat
that russia does in the ukraine though
it's true to say that they've been an
accomplice to what is happening in
ukraine
um but they are more likely
um to launch an invasion of taiwan than
was perhaps the case in the past
because um they see
taiwan as being an affront to their
grievance-based nationalism
and i would guess that if things started
to go badly wrong in china
and if they started to worry about their
control over the over the public and
they might think that was a way of of
getting support i don't myself think
it'll happen i think they're too smart
boris johnson says that they will
continue to
hold china
to its commitments
or try to hold china to its commitments
on hong kong
do you think that's possible
and
what should the british government or
the international community be doing
it's true that we should continue to
call out whenever china does anything
that breaks its commitments in hong kong
and it's true particularly true that we
should work with others
us australia
european union canada
to put pressure on china over hong kong
all that is true
whether they will take very much notice
i'm not sure
but we should make we should make sure
that they're paying a price for not
taking notice
and just finally is there a problem
asking china to
adhere to international agreements when
on the face of it
the government at the moment is
threatening certainly to breach an
international agreement over the
northern ireland protocol
of course that makes our position
morally um less sound than it should be
i don't honestly think that two
things are quite
comparable but nevertheless we would be
on stronger ground if
we were making it clear that we didn't
breach international agreements
ourselves because
sooner or later if and when we do
reach international agreements it will
come back and hit us like a boomerang